welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
[Music]
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show where
you sit down with your favorite
comedians
and find out if they grow up classy or
if they're complete trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful scorching day here
at gas digital studios in the big studio
in the east
village it is sticky out there gang i
got a lot of gold bond on right now
a lot of gold bonds can make a cake down
there if you want it
my co-host is coming at us from right
next to me
he's my good pal ladies and gentlemen
next time you're reaching for a best
buddy
make it a kippy because this kid tastes
great and he's less fitness
not too shabby give it up for kevin
james ryan everybody
hey gang thanks so much the hell was
that happy to be here i'm a little guest
uh happy to be here uh guys as always i
appreciate all the support so far
uh if you haven't already please make
sure you rate review subscribe on itunes
also full video available on youtube you
can subscribe
there as well and it to get all the
bonus features you can subscribe
at the gas digital network uh use promo
code ayg and you get
you save a couple of bucks every month
and we get to wet our beak and that's
why we're [ __ ] doing this
so use promo code a-y-g baby that's
right you get everything in hd and who
doesn't want to see the fat man
in hd but that's either here nor there
we could not be more excited to have a
very special guest
here with us today uh she is one of the
hosts of zeroblog 30 on bar stole sports
she's the co-host of chaps and kate on
siriusxm
she is a united states marine corps
veteran
two tours yes in afghanistan the hellman
province
that ain't [ __ ] rodeo drive i can
tell you that kippy
you and your good time buddy smoking
doobies down in the suburbs she was out
there [ __ ] putting the work
in but the big question in everybody's
mind today is she garbage ladies and
gentlemen
give us a nice big round of applause for
kate mannion everybody yeah
i'll applaud myself thank you so much
thank you for your service obviously
thank you i know that's probably corny
to say i don't know how veterans like
that
no my dad always shies away from it but
he'll get his free meal on veterans day
and applebee's i'll tell you that that's
almost like oh no no no but as soon as
the free boost comes into it i'm like it
was so
hot over there so hard yeah so
now here's the thing that we brought
that up i see a little
uh duality in this now as you know kevin
and i
we're both garbage from suburban
philadelphia
all right now you are a veteran
and i my eyes our eyes veterans can't be
trash
oh i know as a veteran and a marine
corps you'll say you can
all right i know some of those guys
played fast and loose but that's a very
classy thing
however i also know that you grew up in
coatesville pennsylvania
true yes tough one to bounce back from
rip city their main their their main
export is ringworm
[Laughter]
not a good look all right so you have
that going on
and i also know doing a little research
that you originally wanted to be
a dental hygienist yes yes i did that is
the trashiest
of all the dental professions especially
down in that area yeah
a lot of good digging in the mind the
dental hygienist
always was the coolest one in the office
but also
played it the most fast and the most
loose
so very interesting show we have out of
us do you think you're garbage
immediately yes i know i was like am i
supposed to pretend like maybe i feel
good about myself but i don't i
well actually gentlemen i don't believe
that yeah
have my dms all the time on social media
are like are you okay
oh god i should change a couple things
in my life but
is everything going all right with you
right now yeah you still haven't found
your car yet
a lot of these days i will been there is
that a real thing are you missing the
car
well i did find it again but a good six
months uh and
over a thousand dollars worth of parking
tickets
how'd you lose the car it's a long uh it
was more of a i knew kind of where it
was but i knew there was parking tickets
on it and i just didn't want to see it
so i was like that [ __ ] it and then
all of a sudden it was six months later
and i was like covet hit and i was like
i kind of would like to be able to get
out of the city
six months of alternate side parking
tickets it was still there
steep that's crazy that it's still there
yeah so all the time
yeah i know all the money i saved during
covet not being a dirt bag at the bars
went to
one ticket bag on the street wow holy
[ __ ] that's a real dirtbag movie yes
talk about kicking the can down the road
that's tomorrow's problem
i got real hemmed up with that i had my
my car up here
and the same thing i would get tickets
i'll get a couple of days i'll pay and i
would monitor it
but once it gets to like 400 bucks then
they slap the boot on you
yep but the boot's like four bills so i
go out one day to move the car i got
this sticker on there and i called the
placer like you owe 800
and we're towing it in a couple of
minutes i was on the phone to paddy
foley right quick
mom we gotta straighten this out she's
like what do you think you're going to
do i'm like what
i'm [ __ ] doing it what do you mean
cut the [ __ ] check
always a good time six months
why did they call coats what did
coatesville rip city oh rip hamilton
he's a
nba player and i think that's like the
only it's been like two decades now and
it's still this
banner that hangs over the town like
welcome to rip city that's what we got
we used to wrestle coatesville high
school in in high school
and those kids all smelled like burning
wood
every one of them their main sorts of
heat was either coal
or wood pellets that's my favorite story
as of late is that they finally built
this new park and there's always so much
corruption in the town everything
we finally built this new park and
everyone was so excited because they put
one of those splash pads
in it where the kids could play my
parents went to visit it and they're
like yeah we went to check it out and
immediately somebody drove their car up
onto it and started washing their car
that's like all right we're getting
better that ain't kenny bunkport
[Music]
oh my god shout out to goatsville yep
dude there's some towns i'm from
bucks you're from where montgomery
county yeah there's some of the
i you know i'm sure it's like it around
the rest of the country but like there
is just
garbage roots and garbage dna in those
people
outside of philadelphia it's just like
this blue collar yeah
trash that you can never shake because
we're proud of it that's fine
yeah we have no problems with it no
imagine having the balls to drive your
car up to a new park
a kid's water park and wash your [ __ ]
wheel wells that's crazy zero shame
yeah it's nuts moving the nine-year-olds
out of the way so you can get a break
yeah can you kids get the [ __ ] out of
the way yeah i went muddin last night
it was one of those towns like two when
i finally i ended up dropping out of
college but when i went to college
and kids were like oh you're from
coatesville that's where my church went
every summer to help fix up
that's like where the team groups go oh
my god i was in the peace corps there
yeah yeah okay thank you thanks for the
new roof guys appreciate it my mom and i
yeah the new roof and the powdered milk
my cousin did that she joined you know
like some like church groups she was
like i want to give back when she was in
her like something
early 20s or something yeah no and she
lives in kensington and she went to the
two places and they were like
well she went to some organization like
well we either send you to georgia or
kensington so
she's like you could just do your
neighborhood you know what i mean if you
really want how about you just get your
[ __ ] together yeah
yeah start at home tell your neighbors
to cut the grass yeah so tell us about
growing up at coatesville uh what was
the situation do you have brothers
sisters mom
dad what was the give us the works yeah
so my parents are delaware county
they're delco drexel hill and havertown
oh they're too nicer they're on the
nicer edge nicer edges they met at the
swell bubblegum factory which i love
they are there it's a ymca now but they
met at a bubblegum factory my dad was
that's
[ __ ] really working there yeah my dad
was like the gumball room supervisor and
my mom was like the gumball lady and he
looked like
he was like oh yeah billy
[Laughter]
yes so whenever we drive by that why now
my dad's like see that parking spot
right there
i got your mother yeah i said it was my
birthday
yeah so that's uh my dad's one of 13
and like a huge family irish catholic
irish guy my mom's one of nine irish
catholic you can't go through delco
without like you don't want to honk your
horn at somebody it's probably your aunt
rita or something like if you don't want
to be rude
um and then they moved out to
coatesville just my brother and i so
that's it small family out that way
okay but i would say like middle like
what'd your dad do class he was on the
business end of like a dialysis company
he got his history
teacher degree okay but then kids came
along
ended up working at like the hospital
out there and got into like the dialysis
business the business end
that's not bad white collar that's good
yeah not digging ditches
there you go that's all right he left
the gumball factory
left the gumball factory and moved his
way up and then my mom was a sculptural
pathologist
so she knocked the delco accent right
out by like
water you said water get it out of there
no yeah it'd be funny if she was
teaching people to have a worse philly
accent yeah so class what are you doing
yeah yeah today class we're going to say
use
and john i see her face when some of my
dad's sisters are talking and i'm like
don't
probably cringe yeah
so yeah pretty normal nothing too crazy
a little bit like right outside
coatesville and the boonies
like okay had farms on the other side it
gets a little rural
out there pretty quick yeah and i was
the only like all my neighborhood
they all went to the private and
catholic schools but my parents were
like we're paying taxes you're going to
colettesville you're going to public
that's a very old-school irishman yeah
yeah you're paying the taxes for the
school you go into the school
any local farms where you got ice cream
from
out there local farms uh in the nicer
area chester springs or whatever there
was that one where you could like look
at the cows yeah or whatever
never went but we drove by it a lot you
got brya's at home
shut up yeah my mom's favorite joke was
like especially
like who wants ice cream and me and my
brother be like yeah and then she just
speed by it
i was like that was the joke yeah that's
a dirtbag move my dad used to do that
[ __ ] all the time what the [ __ ] where's
your mom steve oh
yeah it was that or who wants to go
bowling and either one we just zip by it
ah
that's [ __ ] too funny yeah all right
so we got that
single-family home you said
single-family home very nice
driveway the whole nine yards driveway
it got shellacked every summer by the
guy who came through and
shined it up yeah yeah hits it with that
nice black coat
yeah it's pretty nice to start the
summer off i love that i know so maybe
i'm not
guys i don't know i had a basketball
pole you did have a basketball night
bees came out of it oh yeah that's real
yeah
but it was there nonetheless yeah i
killed a murderer hornet not that long
ago
you know the murder hornets are moving
into would you check his id first
yeah what's that because if they're like
that big you can't miss them
they're not here yeah they are there was
one in my garage of the day
was cicada killer it looked like a
citicated killer so i might
okay truth be told truth be told you i
wasn't sticking around
yeah this thing was huge and scary and i
went into the garage and grabbed the
[ __ ] can of wasp spray and hit him
he died so he was either a cicada killer
or a
murder hornet all right but you're going
with the scarier story to impress people
i like it yeah
yeah so there i was yeah i had two of
them
i know exactly what you mean i was i was
chasing the ladybug one time in my house
well i did watch man i also i guess not
to sound classier
we did have a separate shed and our own
lawn mower and i did watch my dad run
over a yellow jacket nestled
completely [ __ ] up yeah yeah big time
what did he get all [ __ ] lit
oh yeah and then he ran in the house and
my mom was like get out of the house
like all the bees actually kicked him
back
out and so yeah no views you
trampoline no jungle gym ball tens or
other
what is this the 1920s holy [ __ ]
weatherball
that was my big 13th birthday surprise i
had all the girls over to play
tetherball in the background
that's pretty classy no that's trash oh
tetherball's classy
yes it is this is badminton's garbage
tetherball's all right
yeah huh i don't know about that
tetherball
did he have to pull like the concrete in
to set the pole they didn't do that
like i kept having to put it on all over
the yard
yeah all right you gotta work out now
we're getting into this hanging over in
the winter
yeah so oh my god i always thought it
was real classy at certain playgrounds
they had that game where
it was like a big cup and you would
throw the ball into the thing and it
would come out at one of the different
things
that blew me away i thought it was
awesome you didn't get out much did you
that blew you away
real plastic and not jaggedy metal yeah
that's a fancy
that's pretty classy tetherball all
right that's how are you garbage first
tetherball we're getting it we're
getting a picture here um
let's launch into a little bit of ru
garbage okay we're gonna ask you a
series of questions
please answer them to the best of your
ability answer them honestly okay and if
they start spark any memories
the worst the memory is the better okay
please feel free to tell us you are
talking to two pieces of trash okay so
you already got the tetherball you're
already beating both of us so don't
worry
all right um start a couple of the
basics that we like to do on the show
here what was the name of the street
that you grew up on
roland road roland road
it's not bad fully paved roland road uh
later in life it was it was it was that
like gray super
we all got rollerblades for christmas
and it would like hurt you know it was
like
like your legs i know that one yeah yeah
that's trashy
sorta yeah it wasn't a service road or
anything no not a service road okay
any highways near you no like your house
didn't back up to one of those uh like
overpasses or something one yard between
us
one yard between us that's a buffer
that's enough of a buffer
was it a turnpike behind you no not a
turnpike all right fair enough
pretty good okay all right do you have a
garage
yes okay big question are you garbage
did you have a garage fridge
no did not have a garage fridge no even
now
even now still well they live in a like
an apartment okay 55 and up
that's classy you move to the 55 and
older yeah take care of it
sell the house the property value about
the yard
yeah and clean living yeah it sucks for
us because my parents are starting to
think about doing that and that'll be a
sad day when i'm
when when i lose when you're legally not
allowed in their apartment anymore
yeah hey terry and patty your fat son
can't come over anymore
oh okay there was no second fridge
anywhere not a basement fridge
not a single one was the was the
basement refinished
no shitty basement we had a ping pong
table though
for what it's worth yeah but there was a
lot of like christmas
decorations and junk all that [ __ ]
telescope that we never used
was there a dehumidifier down there in
the basement it flooded all the time
everything was up on those little racks
every now and then like a tropical storm
would come through and when i was a kid
it was like the most dramatic our houses
our house were underwater i did the same
[ __ ] when you walk down into somebody's
basement and you're a kid and you just
get that
waft of musky mold yeah you're just like
ah
dude we did it we redid ours in like the
early 90s
and like fully redid it it was like
we're gonna be for the kids big basement
and it just flooded every year and then
they just never
it just like just cut the drywall off
like a foot high
and my mom would be like your friends
are over go play down the path i'm like
this shit's embarrassing lady this is
like an
active construction site there's a
little mold yeah down there we have a
situation going on my parents right now
um they had a bar put in in their shower
they have a stand-up shower they had the
bathroom read down i really like the
party
it's through my dad for like you know
sturdiness or whatever so you can
have something but [ __ ] couple days
ago when i was home all of a sudden we
get on stairs in the basement
and it's leaking through the dropped
ceilings real trashy by the way
dropping drop ceilings in your hands
drops well we don't need more because
they got all soaked with blackboard you
got exposed ceilings in your house
and [ __ ] and uh and like saran wrap
up everywhere that plastic [ __ ]
we got a big leak in the bathroom they
can't figure it out we've got two
plumbers
and a contractor there they can't figure
out what's going on
but we got black mold in the basement
quit bragging dude you guys gotta
pretend
i gotta talk to your mom she's gotta get
that 55 and older yeah i'll i'll send
you guys a card
yeah yeah a little brochure from
reminder live they're talking about it
because i'm
i was driving myself if they keep living
there they're gonna [ __ ] that house up
and no one's gonna want to buy it we
were driving to my brothers when i was
home and my dad drove by this brand new
55
he's like that's what we're thinking
yeah and i'm like nah you don't want to
live there what are you talking about
because i want to get the house
eventually at the right price
they love it they are in the middle
apartment and their big brag is that
they never turn their heat or air
conditioning on because it's insulated
which is not true it's like a nightmare
anytime you stay there it's like it's
either boiling or freezing
yeah the lights are always off like what
do you guys do what is with that with
parents man
in the winter it'll be freezing in there
my mom was like it's good for you i'm
like no it's not in the summer
it's [ __ ] boiling hot dude my parents
sit around and [ __ ]
my mom will sit on the couch and watch
fox news in a [ __ ]
winter jacket and i'm like this is
ridiculous
she's like well put some clothes on but
i got a hoodie on lady i'm not walking
around in a [ __ ] snow suit yeah what
the
[ __ ] trying to relax a little bit holy
[ __ ]
no garage fridge no second garage that's
a strike against you i know to
say i know what was the name of the
supermarket you went to growing up
acme class classic classic acne middle
of the road
yep does anyone in your family pronounce
it accommodate acme yes i have
several ants that do yes
yes definitely definitely the acme
wegmans was above
that was not wegmans is classy yeah the
top of the line
right so that's like stu leonard's up
here i guess yeah stew leonard's just
nice they got a nice deli counter too
a little bit above paper thin they cut
that ham i don't know what they cut it
with
i know but it's fantastic yeah so acme
was the
and what is it rite aid or no no uh
shoprite can can
shop right yeah right
yeah it was acme or frozen orange juice
shop rights were all right
shop right shop rights are pretty good
okay getting a picture getting a picture
what was the lunch situation when you
were a kid would you pack a lunch or
would your mom
or would give you money for school
usually packed and we had to pack it
ourselves
kind of thing so yeah were they military
and jay
no no not military lunch
try and sneak as many star crunches as i
could in there well those things are so
good yeah once again like middle in high
school it was like a dollar fifty that
a lot of times that she would give me
and i would just get a snapple and otis
bunkmeyer cookies was the go-to
let me tell you something i don't know
if that's a local thing or not but otis
cookies hit the [ __ ] eastern seaboard
or
something like a [ __ ] thriller yeah
they baked them
for an average of 3.2 seconds
they were basically wrong they were so
soft but dude
four of those in a [ __ ] snapple good
night yeah yep fan there were a quarter
for years that's like all i had for
lunch pretty much
yes we were a big rose our squad
rosenberger's iced tea remember
do i [ __ ] put their kids through
college
[ __ ] good stuff all right okay uh-huh
all right i got it we've got a facebook
lunch that's kind of a classy thing i'm
gonna say i know i'm starting but a
paper bag i didn't have a fancy
i'd say i think i i think the paper bag
is class it's like
the reusable dirty you're washing it out
yeah what are we doing here pay a dollar
fifty for a 50 pack
and you're good for a couple of weeks
you know plus those kids that had if you
had a lunch box that's fine yeah
you have a legit lunch box that's fine
but i remember when kids started having
those like square
they were like could they'd have a uh
like a thing of dry icing yeah or like
an ice pack
yeah yeah that kid was always a [ __ ]
nerd yeah yeah yeah
speed walkers those kids speedwalking
yes yes yeah i think
yeah my mom my mom every year would be
like i bought you this for back to
school i'm like you're [ __ ] nuts if
you think i'm taking
i'm not bringing anything home from
school you know what i mean i'm not
carrying this around with me
i wasn't even a book bag guy i hated
book bags ugh i would just carry one
book or two
i still i'm like i'm a big school bad
guy i can't stop it yeah do you call it
a book bag or a school bag i call a
backpack
i'm starting to feel good very
interesting here
okay all right i got one does that when
you go to a family party does anybody in
your family serve buffalo chicken dip
always
[Laughter]
for the listener out there that's not
from the philadelphia hoagie dip is what
we call
garbage it is shredded lettuce
it's great it's great whenever i'm
hammered
and i come back like down the shore
probably go back from eat it with my
bare hands
i just oh god yeah orders are the best i
love
[ __ ] horse nerves i don't know if
hoagie did classifies as an order fully
though i don't think the french would
co-sign on that okay so
it's an appetizer at best the hoagie dip
the buffalo chicken and then there's
always those why are they always wet
those pretzel nuggets
from the pretzel factory they're always
what are the pretzels right
it's the salt yeah the salt like brings
out the liquid
i know i just i did a family party down
in wildwood new jersey and yeah you're
garbage
oh pure trash
everybody goes you're trash we're like
yeah we know that's right um
we had first of all we rented a pirate
ship for my cousin's birthday
went out on a pirate ship it's like it's
25 that's whatever
yeah we had hoagy dicker
the captain now you stole it uh buffalo
chicken dip hoagie dip and the
the taco dip did you ever do taco juice
yes um
taco tips trash and then it's just a
bunch of drunk
[ __ ] potato headed irishmen digging
their hands in there
[ __ ] gross drunk bare-handed so i was
at a communion party
with family and they got a crucifix
pretzel soft pretzel crucifixion
we were all like dunking in the dips and
stuff yeah
it's the best in the name of the father
the sun and the garbage
you know what that reminds me of we had
a we had an italian section of our
family and every easter
uh somebody's grandmother would make uh
like this famous italian cookie for
easter but it would be like a shortbread
cookie
but it would just have a hard-boiled egg
just plopped in the center
a whole what in the shell
that colored or any shell in the shell
like a whole hard-boiled egg just
[ __ ] sitting in the middle of the
cookie
huh real [ __ ] go back to cooking
class or something that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense
huh the communion party though that's
yeah
you don't you don't realize how good the
jewish kids had it jewish kids were
playing
20 30 jesus bar mitzvah yeah did you see
any of your communion money do you
remember
i don't remember but i will say my
communion party was like one of the
biggest bangers of my life i was [ __ ]
sick
yeah my dad would dj on the weekends to
make extra money he would he had to
borrow the equipment from somebody else
but he would dj all around
and so he like i had so i had all the
official dj equipment
yeah that's like [ __ ] as an
eight-year-old yeah and we're like we
could request you know so we're like
requesting all the songs and the whole
family came out yeah i got
i remember opening the money i don't
remember what happened yeah we never
know
that's what happened you never see it
yeah and i hate to say it the
tetherball's nice the part-time dj
that's going down in the [ __ ] yeah
where where was the communion party in
my backyard
okay okay okay halls are really driving
a halls people were in a hall it was not
at a firehouse where a lot of the others
were yeah so they're real i spent a lot
of time at a vfw i have oh yeah uh-huh
make the best meatballs i don't know why
yeah meatballs and mashed potatoes are
[ __ ] top shelf
i don't know what they put in the sterno
but it's [ __ ] great yeah there's also
no windows ever in a vfw no
it's all it's like you're walking into a
[ __ ] black box it's cold as [ __ ] not
a lot of time
in there yeah yeah spicy not a lot of
progressive thinking
all the beers are served in solo like
the clear solo cups
you know it's bad i was in the military
and i very rarely get nervous i get
shaky when i'm walking into it i'm like
how do you feel about uh pillsbury
products
uh big a group on crescent rolls i don't
know if they're always name brands but
definitely slamming them on the counter
the exhaustion they're something
bringing out crescent rolls
that's a level of trash crescent rolls
are trash see that a lot of the
good things are just trashy yes like if
you're making if you're making bread in
five minutes there's you know
you're cutting some corners you know
what it looks like there's no limiting
agent
yeah making bread is an art people study
their whole life to make bread and then
yeah it's just like these [ __ ]
housewives
slamming it down and throwing in the
oven my mom burnt them
every [ __ ] night oh yeah but they
were still love them
on them the brown bottom yeah them in
hot dogs the more burnt the hot dog is
the more i'm in
i agree yeah got a nice ballpark charred
on the outside
medium rare in the center yep all in um
you mentioned the shore where do you go
to the shore
oh see i'm gonna sound fancy again sea
isle city yes
a mix of anglesey wildwood a little bit
but sea isle city is the
his one cousin has a house diner in
seattle i grew up honest i grew up going
to sea isle same here every every year
of our life my dad's whole family run
out like an entire block
where it's like four families jammed
into one house kind of things
yeah right next to the acme did you ever
do it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
did you ever take a vacation where
multiple cars followed each other
pretty much that my whole life that was
the vacation like i
when i finally joined the military i
that was the farthest side i had never
gone past indiana and i was like holy
[ __ ] a real cactus like i remember being
like
like blown away by like real palm trees
and [ __ ] i was like whoa
and yeah i was 20 something at that
point so yeah that was
jersey shore was it was that yeah that
was big
yeah like yeah there's there's parts to
see how that are classy and some
not parts but like it still draws some
trash
absolutely rash still goes it was built
on trash yeah yeah it got they
they kind of turned they turned it
around for themselves in the 80s yeah
the jersey shore was complete garbage
i'd say up until the 90s
[Music]
maybe avalon or someplace like that yeah
there's money there yeah
i mean i quarantined in wildwood that's
where i went nice and wow
look at you yeah wow he had a space to
go quarantine you said that like
i was saying it because it's trash but
whatever yeah i guess i'm classic
i like yeah that's what i'm gonna do i
quarantine i say summer
from herpes he didn't have i had to keep
him off the board
yeah okay uh
what are your thoughts on putting chips
on a sandwich always
always always always always very nice
yeah i can't i feel like
i feel lost without it at this point and
i'm a big i still eat peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches
like horseshoes that's my go-to are you
chunky or creamy
creamy no chunks at all and it's gotta
be
salt and vinegar or like spicy chips
gotta go on the pb and j you put it on
put it on that pb and j
oh yeah oh always always yes that's some
trash and i like
that when i get high [ __ ] light salt
and vinegar chip on a pb and j
it's you guys don't know i can try it
yeah it's really good i like a dill
pickle with my peanut butter and jelly
on it yeah on the side yeah like a
gentleman everything that's right
i'll put chips on anything yeah yeah
this is a little regional
but how do you feel about the product
known as tomato pie
are you a tomato pie family i we i don't
love it
okay i know i like upside down sicilians
hot but i never really loved the tomato
but it was
at the at the communion party or derv
table it was always there
always my last choice for the listener
out there that's not
uh you know not from the area is like
um it's like a square pizza
that's served cold and it just has like
a really thick red sauce on top
yeah it's delicious shout out to
corporals and eat snorton it's an
acquired taste i feel like if you're a
kid eating tomato pie
right like you should you should have to
be 20 to eat a tomato
i see the kids lap it down like [ __ ]
mother's milk we love it
big tomato pie family the cookies with
the eggs in them and
yeah we're starting we're learning a lot
about you that just jogged my memory
that's crazy
i used to be like what the [ __ ] is this
and they used to give them out like they
were handing out [ __ ]
stacks of hundreds like you would get
that as you were leaving easter
they'd be like don't forget to take your
cookie home with you it's like that's
making it to the [ __ ] car it sits in
like it's in the garden
okay does anyone in your family
pronounce the days of the week as monday
tuesday wednesday yes yeah my i
immediately aunt peggy comes to mind but
yeah and peggy is the classic
[ __ ] irish catholic woman from
philadelphia does she play the lottery
probably odds are good she has a place
in anglesey yeah
she dies down at the angle c pub yeah
yeah she definitely
definitely pronoun i have a few ants all
my ants are coming to mind but they
definitely have the delco vibe
yeah very strong and debford new jersey
bit of a mix there
i always i only hear deadpool on the
local radio when there's like a car
auction or something like that that's
when you come on down to definitely yeah
yeah
well it's so outside of philadelphia if
people who got money
real trashy people who got money moved
to dep moved to jersey because they
thought it was like i'm gonna get my
well you know
wait till my number comes in get a
couple of bucks and i'm moving out to
live like i'm putting this whole town
behind me you know yeah
yeah and now it's now south jersey is
just all trashy people
one generation removed from philadelphia
yeah huh
what was the pet situation growing up
just one
i had one fish from the strawberry
festival i made
a shitty fair at the how long did it
live yeah
uh two days yeah his name was night
mover
he only moved one night i like sleepers
huh yeah night movie the fish and then a
cat a black cat named jet
okay that's respectable respectable a
lot of people were saying that if you
name
pet names that are human names as trashy
yeah yeah yeah if you have a dog named
gary or something
i had a german shepherd named mike yeah
yeah mm-hmm yeah because your parents
claimed him on the income tax
yeah so no no turtles no snakes no
hermit crabs
nothing ferrets hamsters guinea pigs we
were not a big
there's a huge nest of bees that lived
in your dad eventually
yeah it was like that scratching dad i
hear scratching the wall no you don't no
you don't know you don't and then it
turns out there's like a thousand bees
an inch from like breaking through the
water holy
[ __ ] infestations they were kind of like
mine they were yeah they were close near
and dear to you
did you ever have a bad infestation like
that growing up no i just said our
wildwood house got termites this year
yeah oh yeah we had skunks for a while
oh yeah pull up the driveway and you see
all their little eyeballs looking
oh they [ __ ] frightened me and they
somehow got in
underneath like the like where the steps
are to get into my to get into my
parents house they like dug through the
concrete somehow like you know on the
side
and they were like they were practically
in the house they were like in the crawl
space they chewed their way in
it smelled like skunk in there for like
three summers summers
dude it was bad what are you gonna call
anybody we did we had someone get rid of
him but it took the guy like six months
to kill him
this guy came out he was like [ __ ]
yeah i know exactly what i'm doing
i think i've told this before he set up
like six traps yeah around my parents
house i woke up the next morning we went
out
there was six different animals in the
[ __ ] traps
none of which were [ __ ] skunks it was
like two possums a dog a squirrel
your dad stuck in one yeah we definitely
thought
that's [ __ ] garbage all right no pets
yeah no pretty quick
one cat i know i'm more and more i'm
feeling you're you're
you know i'm feeling better i say you're
on the line you're on the line
i'm starting to sit taller than this
yeah you [ __ ] pieces of trash over
there
yeah the dad djing on the sides he never
dj'd anything that you were at socially
as a kid like you didn't catch him at
like the prom or anything
no but every he we would throw a big st
patrick's day party every year that's
cool
in the garage and that was where they
would decorate it and he would rent the
he would do the dj equipment and then
after the party i would always get to
rollerblade around in the garage to
whatever i wanted while
everybody was like all hammer how big
was the garage very small
i feel like i could barely fit one car
these guys run into speakies
we had people run over our mailbox every
year it was always like a
[ __ ] show oh that was special times did
you ever get in trouble when you were a
kid did you ever get busted by the cops
um in college i did but at home no i was
really good at sneaking
sneaking around what was the college
college
i played rugby in college okay and i
like watched tommy boy in animal house
as a kid was like that's what i want to
be
so i'm really dedicated so went to
college joined the rugby team moved into
the rugby house
we were having this huge party and i had
broken a couple ribs at a game that day
god so mama had a couple biker rooms
now you're speaking a big man's language
yeah so i had a couple pain pills and
then
we had played west virginia and they
were like they brought up this big jar
of weed that was like super prone
so i'm smoking that and everybody goes
out to the bars and i was like i'm going
to be responsible and wait right here
you guys come back i'll be here yeah you
didn't want to leave the viking alone
that's what i was like
so i was sitting on our stoop drinking a
40 ounce just waiting for my buddy
i think we just passed the line and the
rugby house is literally right across
the street from the indiana county jail
like literally 20 feet just a regular
little street and they're like the
prisoners would always look down and
wave at us and they could see our
address they would write us letters and
stuff
and like yeah dear girl in the purple
hoodie last tuesday ball's in your court
now like [ __ ] like that you're like all
right well you got to give that's
ingenuity on their end though they'll
figure it out
exactly so i'm sitting there and i'm
drinking or whatever and this guy comes
up and he's like oh you rugby girls are
crazy because sometimes the cops would
come out and be like hey
you're getting them all riled up can you
take the party out back or something
because they would be like fighting for
window space and stuff it was really
like yeah
so i was sitting on the stoop and i was
drinking this 40 ounce and i was like
i i had the spinnies like full on
already yeah i remember
you're all biked up hold on using the
word spin
i had just texted a guy too i like booty
called him i was like hey you up like i
was feeling like a 10
at that moment on top of the world yeah
i probably look like a rat like on the
front side like hey
so i just texted him so as he's coming
over the hill
and the rugby some of the rugby girls
are still partying in the house but this
guy comes up it's like oh you rugby
girls are crazy
blah blah blah i remember him saying
something like i bet you won't smash
that bottle
or something like that that's entrapment
i was like i bet you
right into the street i smashed it next
thing you know i remember him like
lunging for my legs and me holding on to
the house
and then people at whatever long story
short i got a
i maybe got a little swingy with the cup
i got a little that's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah that's entrapment well see this is
how i remember it is that he asked me
am i sure yeah she was probably like hey
listen jerkoff
you don't think i'll smash this bottle
dude this took place in the police
station that you walked over to
in hindsight i probably thought he was
the booty call i called over it was like
this will get a stick hard like i don't
know this will get a
rock on exactly uh but it took ended up
taking they had to pull a cop car up i
was i'm a wiggler
i don't like to brag very hard to get in
cuffs you resisted i resisted
i swung i was doing the worm i just
remember looking up as they were cuffing
me and then seeing the guy had called
like standing in the flashlight
i was like oh [ __ ] third room at the top
of the stairs
yeah don't touch my bikes yeah that was
the thing
wow uh-huh holy [ __ ] all right that's
kind of what we're looking for the rest
yes kate i know i'm a wiggler yeah
that's not the term yeah yeah resist you
know i'm sorry i got the jitters
i like how you have these cute little
words for these horrible things yeah so
i took a couple bikies shot some harry
i beat up a copy no big deal
what was the name of the school you went
to did we already say this indiana
university of pennsylvania i.u.p
that's true that's pretty cool anytime
you go to a university in
of that state in another state yeah
right it's always california university
pennsylvania university of miami ohio
[ __ ]
nobody yes nobody's ever graduated
from miami university of ohio if you
have
graduated from that institution please
send us a [ __ ] email
yeah i guarantee 0.0 graduation rate
i think those schools too i had a i had
a couple of buddies at the time you paid
literally none of them graduated like
three years yeah i sure didn't
they there's just because they'll take i
don't want to say they'll take anybody
but they take
a rougher bunch i didn't even think i
applied i think i just showed up and
started going there and they're like all
right
[Laughter]
you get percocet yeah you're ready
where's the nose beers
that's his word
it's my friend's word we'll put it that
way oh man those schools and
i knew a couple kids that went to
satellite campuses and
like penn state satellites
for two years get your grades up and go
to main campus you're [ __ ]
terrible you just start selling coke now
exactly yeah i also i only knew like
three or four people that made the jump
from altoona to me yeah
yeah nobody eight years later they're
still there working at some restaurant
in town yeah your friends at maine go on
pity visits to see you
like yeah sure we'll come out yeah i
think i got a weekend free november
yeah that was taking a bus out to
somebody's [ __ ] school
that sucked that's pretty [ __ ] wow
that's a lot
we were on the fence earlier that kind
of pushed
the el garbagio a little bit college was
a little kooky i feel like that's when i
started to really hit my garbage strap
and then i was one of those kids like
cliche like i got free and i was like
did you drink in high school or anything
i did but like very sneaky like
i was never like yeah but then when i
had college i was like
did your parents find out about the
incident with the fighting the cop
oh yeah oh my god when they can't keep
that one my senior year when they came
to move me out
so like i made it to my senior year and
that christmas break is when i dropped
out joined
terry i was like i became such a dirt
bag they came to move me out and they're
like this is horrible
my dad my parents are like very strict
they go to like pick up the bed and move
it or whatever there's like all these
used
i was like those aren't mine yeah no
[ __ ] they were the last guys
yeah oh the west virginia rugby team
yeah
it's like the only time i've ever seen
my dad cry oh my
what i was like ah yeah
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] kate i really dug into it
i said i'm gonna live this life really
he started
crying well it was until yeah while the
ride home a little bit
oh i think it all hit him my sweet baby
probably had a dj gig that night
all the inmates are waving as you're
leaving kate
i'll see you in three to five she was
great
you got a good girl there oh my god that
is
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh my god i'm sorry she was like
answering the question no we had a cat
you know
god crying that's the [ __ ] bastard
i would rollerblade from time to time
jesus
christ yeah
dude that's too [ __ ] funny oh man
anyways that's so good dude how do you
feel about goguard
that's good pull it back a little bit
were you a lunchables kid
uh before or after i was a giant [ __ ]
uh i would say gogurt's frozen oh yeah
yes that's it i'm talking that is top
shelf
answer right there the older you get the
more you realize all the snacks you
loved as a kid
are a hundred times better frozen i
don't know why
but let me tell you something you throw
a pack of sour patch kids in the freezer
for a couple hours
you got a real little weird to me i tell
everybody the devil dogs the
whatever [ __ ] yeah they suck regular
drinks and they're amazing
yeah they're amazing yes oatmeal cream
pies
somebody somebody had said uh pop-tarts
right yes
pop-tarts no i didn't i haven't seen it
i haven't done it yet but then these
pop-tarts
started selling frozen like more like a
cake version but
this is posters that's a good garbage
question oh were you a toaster were you
a pop tart or toasted strudel fabric
but i feel like toaster strudel families
are the fancy ones oh you would think
that
but i've had toaster shooter recently
yeah and they're garbage
because you got to do the work you got
to put the [ __ ] icing on and it's
never enough
ah it's [ __ ] trash and then how do
you even heat that up
i don't know i was a pop-tart kid i mean
you're nuts cinnamon and sugar pop i was
a toaster's kid we didn't even get
name-brand pop-tarts we got toasters
yeah they suck your dad should have been
djing on the weekends
[Laughter]
gang let's take a quick second and talk
about today's sponsor which i could not
be more excited about i have this
product
in my home i have tried it and it is
absolutely fantastic
and of course we're talking about real
paper
real paper is here to make sure that you
never run into toilet paper
again no emergency trip to the stores no
random napkins
no paper towels no flushable wipes that
clog up the toilet
and aren't good for the environment i
mean even during the pandemic
reel has made sure that their
subscribers have toilet paper
they make an incredibly soft three-ply
toilet paper
delivered straight to your door and not
only
is real super soft and durable it's made
almost entirely out of sustainable
bamboo how amazing is that even reels
packaging
is great for the environment since i
don't use any plastic wrapping
with real you can pick and choose when
you get your shipments so you never run
out of toilet paper again
and the best part about real for every
roll of toilet paper you buy
real helps people in need get access to
clean toilets which is awesome
2.4 billion people around the world
don't have access to a safe toilet
and reel wants to bring that number down
to zero and you can help
just by wiping your butt with real paper
so go to realpaper.com that's
r-e-e-l-p-a-p-e-r.com
and if you use the code garbage you'll
get 10 off a single purchase
or your first subscription order that's
great
do it plus you get free shipping in the
us that's realpaper.com and use the code
garbage use the code garbage do some
good
for the world while wiping your butt all
right back to the show
hey in college how many days a week do
you think you would drink
uh almost seven wow yeah i would love it
yeah couldn't yeah i was that friend
that on a monday night if you didn't
have class tuesday
no i was that friend that you could be
like i know who will come out with me
even though it's a monday night yeah
i was the same guy always i used to even
do worse if i didn't have class on
tuesday
and i'm so on monday night i'd be like
yeah they would go come out they're like
i got at 8 am i'm like dude you've been
guys you were there four weeks in a row
come on or whatever i just i would
convince my friends to just party with
me yep that was
if i had class on tuesday i was still
going out because that was the big thing
for me when i got to college i could say
no like just being able to not like you
really didn't have to go to class
right and when you're at college in the
beginning of the semester and you go out
on like a monday and get [ __ ] up and
you spend the rest of the day
laying around smoking
i went to temple and the cafeteria had
like
draft gatorade if they had like you know
like it was out of a machine
yep and it came out at like 33 degrees
yeah
it saved lives that [ __ ] i missed those
days loitering at the chow halls or
whatever
yeah that's awesome cafeterias yeah
yeah did you used to shop on on military
bases did you go to the exchange
yes yeah we used to go my dad was navy
he was in vietnam and then he recruited
out of willow grove for most of my life
and that was always a big thing the
exchange is on bases and it's like
like there's no taxes no yeah they're
cheaper they're always a little bit
cheaper it's like nice it's like when
you would go to delaware to buy a tv or
whatever exactly
yeah that's a total one sell milk and
jeans like [ __ ] like that but just
before anybody was doing that
that was always a big thing we're going
to the exchange yep maybe stop at the
commissary
get some sausage patties [ __ ] clean
living not the links but the patties the
actual patties when i was new when i was
in because you're talking about military
being classy
officers are classy enlisted we're all
garbage okay for the most part
no offense said with love sure short
shorts but like i used to when i first
got in and i thought
i was like i really did i was like so
badass they taught me like three karate
moves and i was like
i could [ __ ] kill anybody back here
now my hands
yeah i thought i could like take in
somebody
i i literally had a shirt that i wore
unironically
around town oh my god with my dog tags
out that said it was a bulldog and it
said taking a bite
out of the middle east like i wore that
i was like oh i wore that helmet leave
like and now i want to die
thinking about it but i used to be like
i'm dare somebody a [ __ ] dare
yeah i wish a [ __ ] would yeah
you ever got caught
caught you had that shirt underneath
your uniform like guys it's a joke yeah
yeah it was a prank doing a trick yeah
yeah i'll bark holy wow that's something
else
yeah how was the food in the military
obviously not like out in the field it
was probably bad but like
i remember i went to a lot of bases with
my dad yeah and hated a lot of
commissaries
i gotta tell you it was pretty [ __ ]
good it's not bad there'd always be like
hurry up it's
on your fridays like everybody like
there are certain days where you knew it
was gonna be gonna be good
yeah buffalo chicken salad day was a big
one buffalo chicken salad
it's no dip but but yeah
yeah what are you thinking kip
i'm leaning trash man i think your
childhood haley pushed it over
we're finding this a lot like we just
had ari shafir and he grew up uh
orthodox
uh jewish and then at 20
he broke that and it was just like he
became a [ __ ] lunatic yeah so it's
similar you know
you grew up under a tighter regime and
then you were like warning parents this
should be a show for parents
thanks yeah you hear that kids do you
want your kid to be garbage
i gotta let him drink a little bit yeah
at some point you gotta go through that
because it was always the kid at cows
that didn't drink that like like drunk
like a fifth of jack daniels the first
weekend it was like
in the [ __ ] carried out on the girl
or whatever yeah
okay all right i got one here growing up
did you have a do you ever have a cookie
cake for your birthday
no never had a cookie cake that's trash
cause you got to like get them in the
mall or something the mall yeah that was
like
i was jealous of the kids that did yeah
but but looking back it was no good
oh yeah it sucks if you're going to the
mall to get your [ __ ] birthday cake
that's
right they always had eyes on it too
they always put eyes on it like fake
eyes like it was a face
yeah that's real garbage everything was
bringing the kids who brought that into
school for their birthday that was like
oh [ __ ] i mine was always rice krispies
with m
m's in it that was my big homemade
homemade so
i don't like that is class right there
that's
i don't care how many condoms were you
[ __ ] homemade rice krispie treats but
emmy's in it that's
that's love from a mom right there
that'll do that yeah that's pure love
even now um i like an ice cream cake
don't get me wrong
all right but now on my birthday picture
you're more of an asparagus guy
but i love who my mom makes my birthday
cake oh yeah because she always made
when i was a kid chocolate chocolate
cake with buttercream icing and she'd
make it homemade
i tell you what man you get to the
center of a home
cake it's so moist there's so much sugar
that your teeth like hurt
that's clean living i agree your eyes
just rolled back in your head
is there an used condom under the table
now
jesus christ how do you feel about
sherbert not a fan
cool that's good i don't really think
it's good sherbert's trash give me the
good
yeah the poor man's water ice
[Laughter]
are you a fan of water ice yes rita's
yes
yeah i like it all right reed isn't a
soft pretzel good night yep
how do you feel about chipotle
why why so what it just doesn't i still
eat it i just ate it the other day i
just had it today i had it like i have
it once a week probably yeah
i don't good for you chipotle's trash
they try to act like it's [ __ ] they
try to act like it's a little fresher
yes and i think the more they it it's
getting more and more taco bellish where
i'm like this is just like mass made
food that i'm just shoving down my face
here
i still taught like the ortega kids
growing up like that to me
i can eat 50 of them and like the
chipotle so i still am hooked because of
that on the hard tacos
and there's they like fall apart in two
seconds of chipotle that's my problem
with it let me ask you this about the
ortega family pack
uh that has that right big face is it
clean living
or that's clean but i have a question
for both of you did you guys
toast the taco shells yes
i don't think we did that's [ __ ]
because my girlfriend's like you don't
toast them
and i'm like are you out of your [ __ ]
mind you put them in the [ __ ] oven
for a couple of minutes
you're eating them raw now i do feel
like they were browned more yeah
maybe i just don't remember you got to
cook them but some families didn't and
just [ __ ] ate them hardcore
yeah they're stale they're hard to chew
that way yeah it's like the thickest
kettle cooked chip you could possibly
get
all goes back to chips with you did you
ever get peanut butter jelly in the same
jar
no no i hate that yeah that's
that's arguably the worst invention of
the last thousand years
the ratio is not the same there's always
got to be more peanut butter to jelly
yes yes oh see i'm a jelly heavy kind of
guy no
no you can't believe it or not yeah
that's not like a lot of jokes and you
keep jelly in the fridge
but you don't keep peanut butter in the
fridge so why are we combining the two
very nice she doesn't keep peanut butter
in the fridge that's great yeah
we kept it in the fridge growing up oh
sucked
i use a lot of plastic wrap and it makes
it really snappy
yeah yeah yeah yeah i had a bunch of
[ __ ] plastic knives in there oh
there's a little bit of jelly in there
too that was always trash i have cuts on
the webbing of my hands from getting
like haagen-dazs with the plastic spoons
snapping and like i'll just do another
one and they like yeah well you can get
home
around that now will you eat the whole
pint you go for the whole party yeah
absolutely
yeah yeah it doesn't seem like a gal
that's pulling back at the half
yeah some people don't they control it
and they only eat like half like
i'll go into somebody's freezer and find
like a half thing of ben and jerry's
like what are you a [ __ ] cereal kelly
yeah smoke alarm go off or something
yeah
huh all right no sherbert we're pulling
back a little bit here we're coming
coming back into the black
i'm a little confused i think i don't
know what's going on here with her
it's very interesting do you ever have
to
call 9-1-1 on a family member colin i
won't no
i've never had a call no i haven't has
any family member had to call 9-1-1 on
you
no okay i'm in the clear fair enough
yeah did you er is there any family
members that you currently don't speak
to
oh with 13 on that side it's got to be
tough to have no irish uh egos getting
in the way there no
honestly i like they all turned out
pretty great
good weird yeah i actually like love my
entire family
wow i know going over to this guy's
house like walking through a [ __ ]
mind
man oh it's don't mention cousin jerry
yeah for a certain like you know if
they've had a beer or two like i'm just
gonna walk that way you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah other than that for
sure
for sure okay have you ever smoked weed
out of a soda can
yes okay recently
no no not recently probably been a few
years
okay do you drink eggnog at christmas i
hate eggnog thank you
no it's not for you yeah for you [ __ ]
i love it but it's garbage
dairy and alcohol what are we doing a
little nutmeg and cinnamon come on
ugh i love white russians but i can't
that's the only that's the only
exception yeah yeah of course
hmm what's your favorite cereal a
reese's puffs
hands down i can eat a whole box to this
day i probably go through a box a week
and that's pretty i have like the giant
bowl when i'm hungover i love
oh yeah yeah you used to do it in
tupperware's like oh yeah like a big
thing of tupperware it's so good
at the start of kovid i live in a studio
apartment
and i had the huge ass bowl of reese's
puffs and i flipped the whole thing it
was like full of milk upside down
and this is like a hand-me-down 15 year
old lazy boy
and the smell in that couch it was
the [ __ ] nightmare for you what'd you
do with it because i ordered a new lazy
boy because of it i was like i can't
live
but it's not getting here until this
week and i ordered it like four months
ago
hold on a second that's gotta go in the
file too as a plus she's got
new lazy new lazy boy boy you got a lazy
boy what did that say
all right if you don't mind a sales game
would that set you back for a new lazy
boy for a lazy boy love seat over a
thousand dollars
yes yes yeah not too shabby i know
how much cash you have on you right now
that's a good question you should ask
people
i think that's like a lot of wrinkled up
ones we do someone
oh yeah cause he was like he's got a
little bit of cash on him like greg
fitzsimmons
and i was like what do you got in the
wallet he's like i was like i guarantee
you got a hundred you get a fresh
crisp like right from the bank wrinkly
that's
i know that's pretty [ __ ] good were
you guys at bagel bites or pizza rolls
family growing up
uh pizza rolls microwave oh microwaves
are all
right at least have the decency to put
them in the oven
everything's better in the oven it was
always microwaved but on a paper towel
to soak up the grease and then you have
to nibble the edges so the grease
wouldn't burn you
oh see that [ __ ] in the middle was
nuclear yeah
what was your frozen pizza situation
growing up did you guys mess with that
frozen pizza oh yeah eelios all the way
we're big helios people
yeah that was did you ever gentlemen's
get a nice round of applause
did you ever make it in the microwave
yes all the time
all the time there's something about
getting out of like getting off the
fresh off the slip and slide out back
and running in for it you had a slip and
slide for a frozen goger and an
alias that's clean living right there
that's a good slice of americana right
there yeah did you ever upgrade and have
yourselves a stouffer's french bread
no never any stouffer's products in the
house growing up
no ouch actually we every now and then
frozen lasagna but
i don't know if it was still first there
you go but definitely the big brick
anything stouffer's frozen is [ __ ]
something else
i don't know what to put in it um
let's do this something we haven't done
in a minute sure
chocolate milk yes growing up uh yes
pre-made no syrup syrup ah
what would you get hershey's nice final
question what do you put in first the
milk or the syrup
don't let me down kate oh my god i know
what i do but i don't want to let you
down
tell me i put the here's what i do i put
the milk you're blushing right now
because i feel like you're a guy who's
like i know my chocolate milk yeah i
don't want to be wrong
i put the milk in i start swirling it
already
and then i pour the chocolate into it so
it swirls as i go
holy [ __ ] the boys round of applause for
that
thank you yeah wow i know i like to
watch it
we've never had that i don't think yeah
that's like how you would make it if you
worked at a mulch shop
you know what i mean get it going my i
think i'm garbage i was
i put the syrup in first yeah because i
want to see it
i don't like it that when you get to the
bottom of it then though it's like too
much too much
that's why you have the long ice
teaspoon to scoop up the the hardened
i mean dude if you're buying other
utensils for your chocolate milk
you're living a bad yeah dude nobody had
ice teaspoons i'm the [ __ ]
i don't even know what the [ __ ] iced
teas i'm thirsty you're long teaspoons
for iced tea glasses
i don't know some restaurant hat on my
mom my mom's
your mom's not class enough to buy
separate separate spoons for her iced
tea
or make ice cream by the way she's
making powdered iced tea yeah we were a
crystal
same here powdered iced tea yeah yeah
every once in a while she'd break out
the sun tea
apparatus oh which sucked as a kid
zero sugar fancy what's the sunti
apparatus it's like a glass pitcher that
you put out in the sun with a bunch of
tea bags and some water water
that was weird [ __ ] no you guys ever do
that something never heard that
somebody backed me up on this with an
email or something i was a green pitcher
with the powdered milk in there or the
powdered [ __ ] iced tea
would you leave the wooden spoon in
there to stir it every time
leave the wooden spoon in there what are
you talking about like the spoon that
you would stir the iced tea with we used
to leave it in the pitcher
so that when you got it out you could
freshen it up by starting there's no way
that's
passing a [ __ ] health inspection
right you can't be leaving a wooden
spoon in your drink
i'm not running a bread it's a porous
culture trap
yeah you're your family you gotta box
the sugar up a little bit
all right i think i only got one or two
more here do you put the ketchup out at
thanksgiving dinner
no yeah that's for what i don't know my
son
my cousin does it oh yeah i don't know i
keep an eye on this guy oh yeah oh my
god i've never
seen it or heard of it my whole life and
then this down
down the shore and somebody was like
this is what she does and i was like oh
my god
uh-uh yeah don't do that also too
somebody wrote in have you ever had
chicken for thanksgiving
get your [ __ ] [ __ ] together
you don't have a big enough place to
have thanksgiving if you're serving
chicken
that's sad with a little ketchup on it
yeah it's tough
have you ever had as a family do you
ever remember having a
whole turkey on any other day but
thanksgiving
no that's real trashy yeah never yeah
because you know my mom's been breaking
out a lot since i've been going back and
forth to the burbs
turkey london broil have you ever heard
of this no it goes great with a sun
teeth
so nice yeah it's a [ __ ] it looks
like steak
but it's turkey it's dudes your mom for
real tell her to watch emerald live or
something it's [ __ ] spicy
that's a good meatloaf though i'll tell
you that pretty good on eggplant
okay all right i got i got two more here
uh
are you a twisted tea or a hard seltzer
kind of gal twisted tea
yeah twisted tea lights with a floater
on top oh
yeah all day what's the floaters listen
tell them what a floater is but i get
vodka in mine
but i you dump yeah you dump liquor on
the top of it so it's floating at the
top
where are you getting this down the
jersey shore that mostly is where i do
it yeah
floater and bars in philly area did you
know i
there was a study twisted tea light
philadelphia is like that area is the
number one one
i could imagine dude lights on the beach
it's the best
[ __ ] team up all day long yep do you
drink white claws or anything like that
we just went over this that's right oh
heart seltzer's okay
yeah more of a twisted tea okay fair
enough yeah
um this did you drink milk with dinner
growing up
yes always yes always still do it
every now and then i know i know i know
i know milk with spaghetti every night
sometimes
yes she's trash everybody that's it
wrap it up take down the lights move the
tank it's not bad
milk and garlic bread oh so good
it even texas toast yes oh man there's
nothing [ __ ] better than an ice cold
glass i think that's the now in the
coffin for me
do you often have breakfast for dinner
growing up or now yes
yeah who would cook at your mom or your
dad mom always wow
it was hamburger helper breakfast for
dinner or like she called it goop but it
was just elbow macaroni with spaghetti
sauce in it it was like special
we started this thing out at a certain
point i'm sitting there i'm like
we're never gonna get to her and then
she starts talking about fighting cops
and
yeah wow yeah the dad crying was a real
turning point in this story i'll tell
you that
yeah man holy [ __ ] huh
i gotta go garbage hundred percent
great job man i was starting to feel
good and then
i think your childhood seemed pretty
tight
you guys your parents are on a tight
ship but then when you got in charge it
kind of [ __ ] spiraled out a little
bit that's been the trend
hamburger helper though that that came
out the breakfast would you guys eat at
the table mostly or just sometimes would
you eat in the living room around the
table we're a big table people tv on
simpsons
always oh yeah it's always a simpsons if
you're watching the simpsons at family
dinner come on
that's no good yeah your parents would
watch that
it would just be honest yeah
100 garbage right there yeah all right
that was awesome thank you so much has
anyone been not garbage
i've been listening seems like
everybody's trash for the most part for
the most part we had a couple we just
had somebody in
uh karen feehan that wasn't um oh yeah a
couple other comedians that
that weren't but typically yeah the bar
is love for
makes me feel like comedic people you
should feel great that's a great listen
what you just described is a great
childhood a great [ __ ] college
experience
and a great way to be the garbage is
something that we should that we embrace
on this all right yeah yeah
yeah all right i love it 100 thank you
so much
anything you want the folks out there to
know where can they find it where can
they see you
uh zeroblog30 it's podcast military
oriented but it's just light and fun and
it's for everybody whether you served or
not
it's just twice a week tuesdays and
fridays comes out on itunes or wherever
you can find podcasts
uh just try and keep it funny that's it
and then siriusxm four to five p.m
monday through friday
very nice and yeah that's pretty much it
buddy thank you so much thank you love
having you kippy what do you got for him
uh as always just make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes on youtube as
well and if you want to join gas digital
to get all the perks there go to gas
digitalnetwork.com use promo code ayg
you save a couple of bucks and we make a
couple of bucks yes i want to push that
even further
sign up for gas digital you get to watch
the episodes in hd
quality you get to be in the [ __ ]
live chat going back and forth with me
and kippy
and we're going to have a lot of great
extra content coming down the line we
want you guys to all be a part
of it at age foley and ice on twitter
foldygrams on instagram
uh what an episode yeah it was great
thank you so much fantastic
if you guys sign up for it my dad will
come dj one of your partners
[Applause]
oh that would be awesome yeah if we
could get your old man the dj to
christmas people
he could do the christmas party that's
good stuff gang thank you so much we
love you guys and we will see you next
week
peace peace